-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back
to the Captain's quarters.
As we told you yesterday,
Giant Lobster Nemesis
won our Twitter poll
for which Sea Captain B-plot
we should further explore
and I want to assure you,
we're workin'
on writin' that up.
Now, there was a fourth option
on the poll, called Other,
and some of you have asked
what would've happened,
had that won.
Well, I'll show you right now
because you guys really
dodged a bullet.
We were gonna
introduce a duck.
He was gonna be kinda like
a nebbishy,
neurotic Brooklyn-type duck,
who lives in the
Prospect Park duck pond
and is always trying to talk
to you about his problems.
-Being a duck is hard.
It's just like, you know,
people are always throwing
breadcrumbs at me
and it's like, you know,
I'm actually trying
to lose weight, okay?
Quack.
-So just be grateful
Giant Lobster won
because, while many of you
hate the Sea Captain,
all of you would've
despised the duck.
-How do ya like me now?!
-And, hey, speaking
of the opposite of winning...
-Reverse segue!
-...as our urgent
national health crisis
continues to deepen
with no end in sight,
the president has been calling
into friendly TV shows
to promise it will
magically go away
and Senate Republicans
have been holding hearings
on a made-up conspiracy theory
about the Russia investigation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
Earlier this week, we found out
that our criminal president,
who, let's remember,
already benefited from two
criminal conspiracies
to interfere
in the 2016 election,
got impeached for trying
to orchestrate another one
in the 2020 election,
and is currently trying
to disrupt the election
by lying about mail-in ballots
and gutting the post office,
is also under investigation
for fraud.
I know.
Try not to be too shocked.
This guy collects fraud charges
like parking tickets.
One day, he's gonna open up
the glove compartment
of his golf cart
and there's just gonna be
a bunch of warrants
for his arrest in there.
Pretty sure half of the papers
he brought to his Axios
interview were summons.
[ As Trump ]
You know, if we're not
doing better
than any other country
with testing,
then why am I
"hereby summoned to appear"?
And, look, as not shocking
as a fraud investigation is,
it's still a huge deal.
And then, yesterday,
we found out
that Trump's bank was subpoenaed
by those same prosecutors,
suggesting the investigation
of his business practices
is more wide-ranging
than we knew.
Honestly, I'm just shocked his
business has any records at all.
I bet if you open a file
cabinet at Trump Tower,
it's just a family
of hissing raccoons.
[ As Trump ]
Do you want my tax returns
as much as you want rabies?
In any other world,
this would be the biggest
news story of the year,
but there's just barely
any room for it.
Hey, remember how the news
used to end
with a cute story about a cat
who learned how to play piano
or some kid who found
a Mickey Mantle rookie card
in his grandma's attic?
Now, every newscast
basically ends --
We close tonight with a story
to make ya smile.
The president has been selling
artifacts from the Smithsonian
to Kazakhstani warlords
and replacing them
with forgeries.
Isn't that something, Deborah?
[ Laughing ]
"It sure is, Ken."
We'll see ya tomorrow.
Because even stories
of fraud and bank subpoenas
got swamped by the president
deciding to venture
out of his right-wing
media bubble earlier this week
to sit down
for the aforementioned
disastrous interview with Axios
that could've also doubled
as a intake exam
at a psych ward.
Jonathan Swan,
the interviewer,
shoulda just held up
some inkblot tests.
"And what do you see here?"
-It is what it is.
-Okay.
That's very interesting.
So, to regain some self-esteem,
Trump rushed back to the
friendly confines of Fox News,
calling in for long,
rambling phone interviews
with Lou Dobbs
and the Fox & Friends,
where they'll let them get away
with any lie,
no matter how outrageous.
And, when the topic of the
coronavirus pandemic came up --
you know, the deadly plague
that's currently killing
over 1,000 Americans per day --
Trump repeated one of his
most sociopathic lies.
-My view is the schools
should open.
This thing's going away.
It will go away
like things go away
and my view is that schools
should be open.
-Is he talking about a pandemic
or a summer romance?
[ As Trump ]
Oh, you know, we'll both
go back to school
and it'll go away,
like things go away.
But then, I'll find out
you didn't go back to Australia,
but I'll play cool
in front of the T-Birds.
You'll get mad.
Anyway, open the schools.
And, seriously, just stop
saying stuff like that.
You've been saying it
for six months
and it's been both wrong
and dangerous.
Of course, you know,
if you're a New York City
real estate crook, like Trump,
things really do just go away
because you probably have
a bunch of criminal goons
around you to make 'em go away.
Trump probably just
never realized
that was what was happening.
[ New York accent ]
Mr. Trump, you know
that pesky detective
who's been sniffin' around?
Let's just say he went away.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, that's great.
He took a vacation?
[ New York accent ]
No, I mean he sleeps
with the fishes.
[ As Trump ]
Oh! He has sex with fish?
-Hey, uh, Seth,
what has one thumb, a hook,
and has sex with fishes?
-I don't know.
-This guy!
[ Laugh ]
-You're awful.
-Well, at least I didn't just
kneel behind a painting
and take a picture
of my own thumb.
-Fourth wall, anyone?
Seriously, you can tell
how much easier
the Fox interview was
than the Axios interview,
just from their faces.
The Fox & Friends look like
vacant spouses
in a loveless marriage
who stopped feeling
anything years ago.
I mean, look at 'em.
They look like
they just caught a glimpse
of their reflection in a window,
holding a bunch of shopping bags
from Saks Fifth Avenue,
and they're thinking,
"All the Fendi bags in Manhattan
won't fill the hole
inside of me."
Meanwhile, Swan looks like
his dog just got up
on his hind legs
and asked him for some money.
[ As Trump ]
I can't tell you
what it's for, Jonathan,
but I need it like yesterday!
At another point
in the Fox interview,
Trump claimed the country
was doing great,
as long as you ignore
the parts that are really bad,
which is, you know,
most of the country.
-You look at a map
and white means good.
Most of the -- most of the map
is in the white color.
The red color is
the corona or potential
and it's a very relatively
small portion.
-Yeah, just ignore
the red parts and we're fine.
Kinda how a plane crash is
actually a successful landing,
if you ignore everything
besides the black box.
-Ah, what's the deal
with the black box?
They should make
the whole plane out of it!
[ "Seinfeld" theme sting plays ]
-As of today,
only eight more shows
with the Sea Captain,
I swear.
-That's what you say!
You don't bring me with you,
there's gonna be a [bleep] riot.
-Second, it's just not true
that the red parts
are a small part.
Look at The New York Times
case map.
There are a ton of densely
populated areas in the Sunbelt,
you know, places where
lots of people live.
That's why the corona map
looks like this map,
of where people live.
We have a fourth
of the world's deaths
and we're still recording
50,000 cases a day,
while other major countries
are recording a few hundred.
You can't just take
a random part of the map
as a success story,
if no one lives there.
[ As Trump ]
The Mojave Desert
has never been safer,
but the fake news
never mentions that.
And yet, as shocking as this
blatant denial of reality is,
it's by no means unique
to Trump.
It's endemic to the entirety
of the conservative movement
and the Republican Party,
and has been for a long time.
For example, while Trump was,
once again, promising
that the pandemic
would magically disappear,
what were Senate
Republicans doing?
Were they rushing to extend
the expired $600
unemployment benefit
or the eviction moratorium
or the Paycheck Protection
Program for small businesses?
Were they holding hearings
on the preventable deaths
of 160,000 Americans?
Nope!
They were pestering
former Deputy Attorney General
Sally Yates
on their insane
conspiracy theory
that the Obama administration
spied on the Trump campaign
to frame him in the
Russia investigation
and, not surprisingly, most
of their questions backfired.
-You don't like Donald Trump,
do you?
-I don't like --
I don't respect the manner
in which he has carried out
the presidency,
-Okay. You despise
Donald Trump, don't you?
-No, I don't despise
anyone, Senator.
-Miss Yates,
when did you first become aware
that the Obama administration
was surveilling
the Donald Trump campaign?
-The Obama administration
was not surveilling
the Donald Trump campaign.
-These guys are so easy
to checkmate.
[ As Kennedy ]
You despise Donald Trump,
don't you?
What, you don't?
Well, well, now, what am I
supposed to do with the rest
of my five minutes?
That was my ace in the hole.
And, Ted, you weren't prepared
with a follow-up?
You didn't think she'd just
shut down your [bleep] question
in one sentence?
"All right, Ted,
it's all on you today."
[ As Cruz ]
Don't worry, guys.
I got this.
"I see you only have
one index card there, Ted."
[ As Cruz ]
Yep. That's all I need.
"You sure?"
[ As Cruz ] It's a lock.
"What if it doesn't work?"
[ As Cruz ] Oh, it'll work,
or my name isn't Ted Cruz.
"Isn't your name Rafael?"
[ As Cruz ]
Dammit!
Well, then, I'll just hide
behind my facial hair.
Trump is not unique
and he's not an anomaly.
He's the culmination of decades
of conservative politics.
His lawlessness, racism,
sociopathic incompetence
are endemic to the entirety
of the modern Republican Party,
which is why it's
not enough to beat him.
We have to fundamentally change
the system that produced him.
We can't just pretend that,
as long as Trump loses
in November,
the conditions that
created him will just...
-Go away, like things go away.
-Did you enjoy your first
"Closer Look"?
-Yeah, it was fine,
but I gotta get outta here.
I have a doctor's appointment
I've been trying
to schedule forever.
[ Chuckle ] The webbing in one
of my feet is all messed up.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
We've been talking
about City Harvest
since COVID began
and, now, more than ever,
they need your help
feeding New York families.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.